after the soul rending gut-punch of
infinity war and man and the wasp is
like an afternoon trip to baskin-robbins
it's colorful splashy and fun without
too much emotional weight I get shared
how was school today still that
definitely isn't to say that everything
got a neat resolution at the end of the
movie true to form for Marvel films
ant-man and the wasp ends on a slippery
slope covered in cliffhangers and
unanswered questions well grab some
orange slices and watch out for
tardigrades because we're diving deep
into the quantum realm to clear up some
of the nagging questions you might have
had after seeing ant-man and the wasps
obviously spoilers ahead wasp evolution
clearly the quantum realm is a crazy
place we first saw how bonkers it is in
the first unmanned when Scott Lang
nearly got lost after shrinking between
the molecules of Yellowjackets suits it
gets even worse when Hank Pym takes us
in a space person to the quantum realm
and ant-man and the wasp
he is a rough reenactment whence hang
send there he almost immediately starts
losing his mind thankfully Janet shows
up just in time to fix him with a new
quantum powers so what was up with her
as Janet briefly explained the three
decades she spent in the realm forced to
evolve in some strange ways to deal with
the madness of the quantum realm part of
that evolution apparently gave her the
ability to influence quantum particles
when Hank got lost in his own mind she
basically guided him back to sanity
quantum healing most of the story arc
involving ghosts
aka Ava star deals with her search for a
way to cure her quantum phase shifting
condition her powers made for some
visually amazing fight scenes but a
character is also in constant pain and
inching closer to the grave with every
moment setup parts not good to end her
suffering
Ava concocts a plan to ambush Janet Van
Dyne on her way out of the quantum realm
and siphoned Janet's stored quantum
energy to do so she uses a sleep chamber
built to help stave off the effects of
her condition although nobody ever
explains exactly what it is by all
appearances it's designed to focus or
manipulate quantum particles in a pinch
though it can apparently draw particles
into itself it turns out there was no
need to fight about it though because
Janet is more than happy to cure Ava
Infinity fallouts in case you still
haven't seen Avengers infinity war
fair warning
we're about to get into some tiny
spoilers here at the end of ant-man and
the wasp
everything's been patched up in the
ant-man universe and then like a punch
to the face the mid-credits scene came
along to remind us that this happy
little ant-man universe actually exists
within the big mean MCU where Thanos
beat the Avengers and dusted half the
universe as the mid-credits scene shows
for an instant Hank Hope and Janet are
now on the list of finger-snap
casualties shrinking timeline without
major connection to infinity war it's
worth taking a moment to clarify the
timeline of everything that happened in
up man and the wasp despite being
released after infinity war ant-man and
the wasp takes place before the events
of the film right before it by all
accounts the movie doesn't mention how
much time has passed between the main
film and the mid credit scenes but
however long it was that time gaff
essentially contained infinity war when
Scott jumped into the quantum tunnel
Thanos is presumably finishing up his
gollnitz over in Wakanda putting the
ending of both movies at just about the
same moment chronologically but this
connection also leads to some
interesting new developments for
infinity war Marvel Master Mind Kevin
Feige has been pretty upfront about
that's a man wasp also connects directly
to Avengers for these characters are
going to be very important going forward
if that's the case and there's a good
chance that all the Fallen Heroes in
infinity war will make a comeback it
could be that hope Hank and Janet along
with the rest of the casualties of
Thanos finger-snap weren't destroyed
outright but instead transferred into
the quantum realm and speaking of that
place lost in the quantum realm ant-man
and the wasp certainly left one of his
heroes in a big cliffhanger when the Van
Dyne disintegrated while Scott was in
the quantum realm he apparently got
stuck there not only other people who
know how to get him out gone but they're
probably also the only people who even
know he's in there that opens up an
interesting possibility after spending a
long time in the quantum realm Janet Van
Dyne learned how to manipulate quantum
particles if Scott spends enough time
sandwiched between realities he could
feasibly develop the same ability that
would give him a definite upper hand
against Thanos in the future especially
if as fans have speculated the Infinity
stones are somehow tied into the quantum
realm thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
you
[Music]